Voice-over Hank: Good morning, John.
So, I went to France last week, where I was
presenting at a ridiculously fancy advertising
industry convention and I spent most of my
week alternating between just being tremendously
satisfied at how pleasant everything was and
being powerfully disturbed by ostentatious
displays of wealth.
A friend of mine had a friend who had a yacht
and they were like "You should come and see
this yacht" and I was like "Dude, I've seen
boats before" and they were like "No, this
is not a boat."
And so I went and indeed, upon arrival on
the boat I immediately wanted to see the engine
room and the water treatment and desalination
systems, the yacht was very cool, and very
pretty.
It has a crew of 12 people who live and work
on the yacht and there's a 24 hour diner and
it costs $250,000 to fill up the gas tank
of the yacht.
Not voice-over Hank: It seems like a nice
place to have a party.
Voice-over Hank: So as far as "Thoughts from
places" places go, the South of France is
a place that is very easy to have some thoughts
from.
Not voice-over Hank: Dog!
Voice-over Hank: One of the main goals of
advertising is to create need where no need
exists, and I had a hard time not thinking
about that as I wandered around and was constantly
besieged by an AT&T AdWorks campaign that
excitedly implied the unquestionable benefit
of more.
In a place that rich people spend lots of
money to go to so they can spend lots of money
at fancy shops and restaurants, manufactured
discontent is both everywhere and invisible.
Not voice-over Hank: The air conditioner's
hitting my toes!
You gotta insulate better.
Voice-over Hank: This is a place where people
go to realize how much they don't have.
Even if you can afford to spend 2,000 euro
on a jacket, there's a store around the corner
with a 9,000 euro jacket.
Even if you can afford a really big boat,
there's a bigger boat next door.
And particularly at this event, not only is
there always something you can't afford, but
there's always a better party with cooler
people that you're not invited to.
I was surprised not that I was a little upset
by all of this, but why I was a little upset.
It wasn't just because of the tremendous difference
that this wealth could make in the lives of
people who are suffering, but also because
the monstrous displays of wealth I saw seemed
to come from sad places, like, mostly from
personal insecurity.
People want other people to know that they
are important and that they matter and that
they're powerful and cool.
John, we're headed into a world of such tremendous
productivity that there is hope in me that
someday we will have so many resources that
everyone will be able to minimize their suffering,
but when I see that new world taking shape
in places like Cannes and Saint-Tropez, I
worry that no one will ever be satisfied with
what they have, and so wealth will never stop
concentrating and we won't be able to turn
our surpluses to truly global goals like ridding
ourselves of poverty and war and the global
insecurity caused by climate change.
Of course, at the same time all around I saw
families who loved each other and were enjoying
the beauty and wonder of this absolutely gorgeous
and historically fascinating place.
It reminds me that many of the smartest people
in the world aren't famous.
They're people who are smart enough to realize
that real happiness doesn't come from being
the biggest fish with the most people tripping
over themselves to be like them.
It comes from being personally secure in yourself
and your life and your values and your future.
That has something to do with money, but definitely
not everything.
It also has to do with being comfortable with
the life and with the identity that you've
created for yourself and doing things you
love with people you love.
Not voice-over Hank: Hey Katherine.
Katherine: What?
Hank: Mediterranean.
Mediterra-knee-out.
Katherine: Wow.
Hank: Mediterra-knee-in.
Mediterra-knee-out.
Katherine: (laughs) Congratulations.
Voice-over Hank: John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
(from Snapchat) Hank: What are you most afraid
of?
In the whole world?
Hannah: looking like Tal Shiar.
Also the infinite.
Hank: How are you doing, baby?
Katherine: (sick voice) I had a great time
in France.
Hank: Oh, it's so sad.
Meekakitty: Les poissons, les poissons.
Hehehe hahaha, just kidding it's a cappuccino,
which is Italian and not French.
Woman: Too much France.
Hank: Too much France.
Hannah: Aw, man!
Hannah: This is not how you Snapchat, Hank.
You know sometimes it's OK to just take a
picture, hi guys.
(laughs)